Denis from Atlanta you know [ __ ] big
Dennis what up do what our Brandon sir
boy Dennis out of Atlanta Georgia as you
can tell I'm on the way to go get me a
lot lizard baby yes yes sir
filming Bob but I got a debate topic for
y'all man would you prefer to get buried
or cremated when it's all said and done
let me know Gang Gang buzz buzz I think
a lot of soft people out there gonna say
cream me up Scotty you know what I'm
sayin bury me me too bro
yeah bury me I saw the liquor stove you
feel me that's where I want to be dude
okay [ __ ] bury me brah in case I want
to be come back I want to be haunting
yeah I don't know what to do you know
I'm saying movie can bump us back to
live with some stem cells
yeah these dumbasses burn their bodies
you're screwed either way
yeah you know exactly how a lot of
people you're gonna keep population down
a lot of people can't come back now put
me in that earth put me on a nice tree
or some [ __ ] you feel me yeah put me out
of shape yeah Shawshank me brah put me
out there put me in your garden put me
on her to Children's Place play area
yeah baby now my kids school yeah a
little bastard yeah a little-little
Daniel found a [ __ ] occipital bone
over there what happened you know yeah
one down this big-ass beef rib bone like
on the Flintstones like throw me into
the Tar Pits a LaBrea baby dinosaurs
yeah cuz my son says dice indoors and as
you say yeah
putting brontosaurus get asked me for a
toy said public ham one these Dyson
doors when you say Dyson or grab that 20
that's the cutest thing ever I would say
this an and what does this guy want to
do bury it or cremation okay what do you
guys do you mummifies each other yeah
actually mummifies each other it's like
hitchens brought chips they call them
you chips yeah we just made it huh what
another's gypsies they did gypsies do
asphalt most of them doing asphalt out
there in the Midwest oh you just fight
each other bare-knuckle to the death who
they this is a wild still your want they
do HVAC a lot of yeah shut the gypsies
yeah they'll do asphalt yeah what do you
guys do either one it's more of a money
thing if you have money then you get
then you get buried but if you don't
have money you get cremated and maybe
Josh's get spread somewhere yep it's
always weird people that get cremated
and they have the ashes in their crib my
[ __ ] over the Pacific Sun did get a
little dandruff on that great white you
feel me oh milk and egg series it'll
make a nice little cake of this it's
just gonna be real sweet I too much
candy Doug what are you guys doing over
there in the urban community yeah I ran
Arizona sorry there's oh hey spread me
all over Mesa Arizona really yeah Wow
little little fertilizer for them cactus
yeah I don't deal a monster
major just thrown out the window of a
car that's Mesa
that's a thought about have you I
thought about honestly being shot out of
a cannon in with schoolyard first kid
that runs up and [ __ ] touches my body
gets whatever money I have it's not bad
idea because most of the kids gonna be
scared there's gonna be one creepy
[ __ ] kid who's gonna wander over with
shit-eating grin on his face and do it
steal one of my eyeballs out of my head
with a stick and I'm like that's the
winner brother yeah what am i doing my
like what you know I'm saying yeah my
body in one of these eggs and the kids
searched for it some get cab eggs some
get my body think egg think like a
Cadbury egg bro
man this eggs weren't a shitty hat man
this egg has some tight-ass G man they
say got a big-ass dick all right
there's a kid's finding those eggs man
yeah all right what else we got yeah
what happens is what is probably
girlfriend on fire
what's going on 66% cremation I don't
burn my body mm-hmm
up next this is Mark sweat I need a
casket either bury me like True Blood I
pop up out the dirt you feel me baby
yeah baby break your low so hometown for
you Dark Arts bury me dude mm-hmm I see
you sookie sookie sookie that's Bill
Compton okay I'm sweating broke a sumo
wrestler with a eating disorder here
just looking outfit I've ever seen -
weird
Oh feel yours from Alan
okay somebody plays goalie at a Taco
Bell jump on this problem
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]